معنا من بيروت العميد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي سياده العميد مرحبا
بك استهداف الاراضي الروسيه بالذخائر
العنقوديه هذا ما تدعيه روسيا في الوقت
الراهن هل هناك امكانيه للتحقق بصوره
قاطعه من ان هذه فعلا هي الذخائر
العنقوديه التي جلبتها اوكرانيا من
الولايات المتحده وتعهدت بالا تستخدمها
على الاراضي الروسيه
محمود لدى اوكرانيا سلاح عنقودي او ذخيره
عنقوديه واستعملتها حتى روسيه استعملت ضمن
اوكرانيا
الزخائر العنقوديه عندما نتحدث عن بيل
جورود تبعد تقريبا 70 كم عن خركاف تبعد عن
الحدود الاوكرانيه 30 كيلومتر تقريبا
المدفع الامريكي الذي يطلق الصواريخ
الجديده مداه الاقصى 30 كيلومتر وعاده لا
يوضع المدفع على الحدود لا بل يوضع خلف
الجبهه وهذا امر يبعده عن
داخل الروسي اللهم الا اذا كان استعملت
هذه القنابل العنقوديه لتجمع مشاه معين
لانه هذه الذخيره هي الديولوس يعني
استعمال مزدوج منها ما هو
لمضاد للدبابات ومنها ما هو مضاد للاشخاص
واليوم يبدو ان هناك حركه مهمه روسيه
باتجاه
باتجاه ليمن الحشد للكثير من القوات بهدف
تثبيت القوات الروسيه الاوكرانيه او حتى
شان هجوم معين طيب ماذا عن الاستراتيجيه
الاوكرانيه حاليا في القرم في ضوء الحديث
الاوكراني عن ان موسم الانفجارات في القرم
قد بدا
ماذا تفعل اوكرانيا هناك ماذا تريد ان
تحقق من وراء ما يحصل
عندما يتكرر الحدث
عده مرات هذا يعني ان هناك استراتيجيه
معينه بدانا نرى من جسر قرش الى
الانفجارات في اماكن مهمه لوجستيه
للعسكر الروسي في الداخل الاوكرانيه من
ذخيره من نفط من وقود وما شابه وتكررت هذا
الامر واذا اخذنا خريطه معينه
وشاهدنا اوراقنا اين هي هذه الانفجارات
كلها على طرق مهمه يعني في القرم اعتقد ما
يقارب 1400 كيلو متر من الخطوط سكك الحديد
يعني سكر الحديد هي مهمه للجيش الروسي اذا
لاحظنا ورقبنا اماكن انفجارات كلها على
خطوط اساسيه تذهب باتجاه تزنكوي يعني
تزانكوي منها هناك خط يذهب باتجاه
زبالوجيا وهذا امر مهم لان هناك معارك
والخط الاخر يذهب باتجاه الغ رب الى
اخرسون فاذا هناك اهداف معينه عمليه حرمان
القوات الروسيه في الداخل الاوكراني من اي
امور من لوجستيه وغيرها خاصه ان الجيش
الروسي يعتبر من المستهلك الاول خاصه
بالذخيره حتى الان عشره ملايين قذيفه
مدفعيه استعملت في اوكرانيا
فيما يتعلق بالسيطره على البحر الاسود او
يعني
مساله استهداف الاستهداف المتبادل للسفن
والموانئ في البحر الاسود بين روسيا
واوكرانيا في تقديرك كيف سيؤثر ذلك على
امدادات الغذاء في ظل الحديث زيلينسكي عن
اتفاق مع النيتو على تامين ممر امن
لامدادات الحبوب الاوكرانيه وكذلك تصدير
النفط الروسي عبر موانئ البحر الاسود
اولا بالمعنى القانوني لم روسيه من
الاتفاق روسيه ما تقوم به هو حرمان
اوكرانيا من التصدير ودفعها بالاتجاه
الاوروبي لانه هناك مشاكل مع الدول اربع
خمس دول من اوروبا الشرقيه على مشاكل وهي
ضد تصدير القمح والحبوب منها لانها تنافس
السوق المحلي اثنين يريد الرئيس بوتين
تحسين موقعه
لاتفاق جديد يحقق فيه بعض الاهداف اما
موضوع تامين ممر او كوريدور من قبل الناتو
فهذا امر ياخذنا الى صراع وممكن اشتباك
وحسابات خاطئه وهذا ما تقوم فيه روسيا
الان بعد ان عرضت عضلاتها استعرضت عضلاتها
من خلال مناورات في البحر الاسود لتقول
انا موجوده وانا اعني ما اقول اعتقد اننا
في مرحله جديده تستلزم اتفاق جديد او
اتفاق القديم معدلا ليردي روسيا بالحد
الادنى وهذا ما يطال بيه الرئيس اردوغان
شكرا لك العميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي ضيفا من بيروت شكرا